Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Here I am, hugging a unicorn,
asking for you
to invest in my idea.
I got a flight of beers for you
guys. Who wants a taste?
Narrator: If the Sharks hear
a great idea...
This is fabulous.
...they'll invest
their own money...
It's such a cool model.
If you're nice, you might get
this for Christmas.
All right.
Narrator: ...And fight each
other for a deal.
What multiple should
I put on cash flow?
You don't put it on cash flow
at this point.
You will make
foolish decisions.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs must
get the full amount
they're asking for, or they'll
walk away with nothing.
You know doghouses
are real boxy.
I know a lot about being
in the dog house.
You'd want to be in this one.
This one's cute.
You want to go into retail?
Very selectively.
Oh, you're breaking my heart.
I want to spank you
like a baby seal.
Narrator:
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Daymond John dominated
the fashion world with FUBU.
Now he's the branding expert
behind multiple global brands
generating billions in sales.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of the world's
preeminent cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
Schwartz:
My name is Henry Schwartz.
I'm from Madison, Wisconsin,
and my company is MobCraft Beer.
Cheers.
I love beer.
I love it so much that,
in college,
my buddies and I decided
to start brewing our own beer
to see what we could
come up with.
It was so good, our friends
and family were asking for more,
and everyone had suggestions
for what they wanted us
to brew next.
All right.
We kept increasing
the size of our batches
and soon partnered up
with a local brewery.
Next thing we knew, we had
our own craft beer company.
Craft beer is a wildly growing
segment in the beer industry.
People are seeing the value
and care
that goes into creating
small batches,
and they want to support local
and independent producers.
How about we do
an old-fashioned sour.
Yes.
Right now, we can't keep up
with the demand for our beer
with the limited capacity
that we have.
Our next step
is to build our own facility
and start cranking out
lots more beer.
There's huge growth potential
for us going forward,
and a Shark would really make
that dream come true
to help us grow
our brand nationwide.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Henry Schwartz,
and I'm the president
of MobCraft Beer.
Today, we're seeking $400,000 in
exchange for 16% of our company.
At MobCraft, we put the consumer
in the driver's seat
and turn their ideas into beer.
MobCraft is the world's first
crowdsourced brewery,
marrying the business model
of crowdsourcing
and the industry of craft beer.
We use 21st-century technology
and the power of the crowd
to create unique craft beers.
We give our customers voice
in two ways.
One --
they submit ideas for beers,
and two --
they vote on what's brewed,
creating a direct,
emotional connection
and building brand loyalty.
So, here's how it works.
Say you love wheat beers,
and you want to try one with
coconut and cacao nibs in it.
You would submit your idea
to MobCraft's website.
From there, our brewmaster,
Andrew, vets that idea
and turns it
into a viable recipe.
It ends up in our monthly vote,
then against craft beer fans
from across the U.S.,
You rally your network
to get your beer brewed.
With an investment
from the Sharks,
we'll be able to build out
our own brewery
and crowdsource a lot more beer
to service the rest
of the United States.
I know it's happy hour,
and I got a flight of beers
for you guys.
Who wants a taste?
Yeah.
Rock on.
All right.
So, we got six beers
for you guys today.
If you just want to grab
a paddle there.
Herjavec: Wow.
All six for me?
Mm-hmm.
Which one first?
Starting at the head of
the paddle -- by the handle.
By the handle.
Remember that coconut
and chocolate wheat beer...
Salut!
...that I was talking about?
This was the crowdsourced winner
two months ago.
-That's really good.
-No, it's a weird taste.
I like this one a lot.
-Thank you.
-What's the second one?
Next down the line
is the Hop Gose the Grapefruit.
-Herjavec: Whoa.
-It has grapefruit in it?
It has grapefruit
and an ample amount of hops.
Wow!
That's really good.
-Thank you.
-Oh, no, it's not.
[ Laughs ] All right,
let's move to the third one.
This one
is our Bat... Crazy.
Why does it look
like a Guinness?
This is our silver medal winner
at the Great American
Beer Festival...
-Wow.
-...from last year.
Is there coffee in it?
5.6% ABV coffee beer.
-Ahh.
-I'm drinking coffee and beer?
Yep.
Ew!
Interesting.
The next one down
is the Vanilla Wafer Porter.
Vanilla Wafer?
This was the winner
in last month's voting round.
Greiner: I love this.
It's very tasty.
This is fabulous.
Oh, my God.
This is awful.
All right. And the next two
are very interesting beers.
These are both sour beers.
This is a sour Belgian double.
-Mnh.
-Is there cider in it?
Oh, that's got vinegar
in it.
It's brewed very similar
to a Belgian style.
[Yell, coughs ]
-I like it.
-You do?
I do.
This one's really good.
What's the last one?
Schwartz: This one
is also a sour beer.
Um, this one's
a sour red ale.
O'Leary:
That is really bad.
Oh, my God.
That's so good.
-That's vinegar.
-Disgusting.
Who drinks vinegar
like that?
-This is really good.
-That's disgusting.
Greiner: Well, at least
we've had a huge variety.
That last one
is just brutal.
So if you can imagine
the people that are...
-Horrible!
-...submitting these ideas
for beers
are the ultimate craft-beer fan.
Let's shoot that guy.
No, I like that one.
Oh, Robert.
You can have mine.
-O'Leary: That is disgusting.
-I like the vanilla one a lot.
So if I tell all
my followers on social media
to put in sardines
and chocolate chips,
and it gets voted to the top,
you'll make it?
So, there's a caveat to that.
To vote, you have to back it up
with your dollars.
It is a pre-order
of that beer.
Okay. How many do you
have to pre-order?
It's a $25 pre-order
for four 22-ounce bombers.
Walk us through an example.
I want to get a beer made
with whatever Mark said.
What'd you say, Mark?
Um, sardines
and chocolate chips.
So I want to get that made.
I go online.
I put up $25 for sardines
and chocolate-chip beer.
-Yep..
-[ Laughs ]
You make it, because a lot of
other people love the idea.
Where do I go get it?
We work with online
liquor stores
to ship it
straight to your door.
How do they vote?
They vote
on the MobCraft website,
and they vote by saying,
"If this beer wins,
I'm putting a pre-authorization
on my card.
If it doesn't win,
no charge goes through.
Okay, so let's go through
the economics now.
Um, when we started
the company in 2013,
we thought wineries in Wisconsin
can ship straight to consumers.
Breweries probably can,
as well.
We hit a big wall,
and that was not legal.
So it took us about nine months
to get the permitting
straightened out.
So we work with online
liquor stores,
and then we have negotiated
that we sell in volume to them,
and they take
a smaller percentage
than a traditional retailer.
Tell us your numbers.
All said and done, we've sold
about $350,000 worth of beer
and $280,000 of that has been
within the last 12 months.
And what will you do
this year?
This year we will do
just shy of half a million
dollars in revenues.
When -- are you gonna make money
off your 500K this year?
Um, this year, since we're
building out a new facility,
we'll have about a $28,000 loss.
-Wow.
-So I'll back up a little bit.
We launched it out of our
university in Wisconsin,
and we just started homebrewing
batches of beer,
and then we said, "All right,
let's see if this can actually
be commercially viable."
So we bought a brewery --
all the guts of one.
How much money did you raise
to do all this?
All said and done,
the founders put in $33,000.
So then you obviously have
a partner.
Yes. Two partners.
And then we also have
an SBA 504 loan.
How big's the loan?
The -- the loan
was for $150,000,
and that was used to purchase
the guts of that brewery
that we started
using about half of it.
What is your background?
Tell us about you.
You know, I found my first
passion of skateboarding,
and I wanted to go get a job
at the local skateboard store.
And I went, talked to the guy.
He said, "Hey, unfortunately,
we're not doing so hot.
We're gonna shut
the business down."
So I was kind of discouraged,
went back home, and my mom said,
"Henry, you love skateboarding
and you want to work
at a skateboard shop.
Why don't you see
if you can buy it?"
I said, "Mom,
I'm 15 years old.
How could I buy
a skateboard store?"
And she said, "You are
passionate about this.
If you put your mind to it,
you can achieve it."
So we bought
that skateboard store.
I ran it for three years
throughout high school,
tripled the floorspace
and inventory.
-Wow.
-What did you pay for it?
Uh, we paid about
$8,000 for it,
built it up to about $50,000
in revenues
as a 15- to 18-year-old.
And, Henry, how do people
find you?
Are you doing beer events?
We go to lots
of beer festivals.
So we started out just going
in the state of Wisconsin.
We went to every beer festival
that we could.
They buy our beer --
How many beer festivals
are there?
Do they have Oktoberfest?
That was 65 beer festivals
in Wisconsin.
Wow.
In any geographic location,
there's multiple microbrewers.
This is a big trend
in beer.
Mm-hmm.
But that practically none
of them run at 100% capacity.
They run
at 40% to 60% -- 70%.
Mm-hmm.
So what I learned
about this business
is the killer
is the capital outlay
to build capacity to brew,
when everybody else has already
spent their money.
Yep.
I'm hooked on that.
I was hoping you'd say,
"Look, we use spare capacity
all around us."
Yeah, you know, we've --
we've looked into it,
and we've found
that with our customers,
the ones who really believe
that craft beer is a craft --
they want to see the beer
brewed on the home front.
So we've got commitment
from the bank,
finance $1.9 million
of our build-out.
So do you ever take one
out of the model
and then go to traditional
distribution?
Forget it.
That's exactly
what we are doing,
and that's what we've done.
We're in Madison
and we're in 75 liquor stores
and about 65 bars.
-How's it going?
It's going very well.
How much you making it for
and selling it
to those retailers at?
So, it depends
on the product segment.
24-pack of cans
costs us about 28 bucks.
It wholesales at $48.
Wow.
-That's...
-Wow.
That's tough.
This is
really premium stuff.
Mm-hmm.
Henry, what I thought you had
here when you came out --
you have these huge advocates
that are willing to spend an
inordinate amount of dollars...
-Mm-hmm.
-...per beer.
Crazy, because they're
part of this idea
that they could brew
their own.
Yep.
Everything else --
everything else puts you --
And would it help if I told you
that those people
were the retailers, as well?
-No, no, but hang on.
Everything else puts you
back in the competition
of the regular
beer business.
Once we have a few beers
that have been brewed and sold
in those new markets...
-Why do you feel so passionate
that you have to own
the equipment where
the beer is brewed? Why?
I think you have
a really clever, unique way
to go to market.
It's a very high-end
product,
but it's just not something
I have a passion for.
So I-I-I'm not a beer guy.
I'm out.
Fine.
Well, I r-- I really liked
the vanilla one.
Mm-hmm.
I thought the coffee one
was interesting.
Kitschy market --
I get it,
but I don't know enough
about brewing beer
and how people are
gonna buy.
I just can't see me
investing in this.
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, I-I hate beer.
So I can't help you. I'm out.
All right.
I love beer,
but I'm Bud Light.
This is not my taste.
I know it's a hot area.
It's just not for me.
So I'm out.
Henry, I think that you came up
with this incredible model
to tap into
this amazingly hot trend...
Mm-hmm.
...and you could make a ton
of money riding this wave.
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Kevin is Henry's last chance
to get a deal
for his crowdsourced
beer company, MobCraft.
Henry, I think that you came up
with this incredible model
to tap into this
amazingly hot trend...
Mm-hmm.
...and you could make a ton
of money riding this wave.
But you want to get dragged
into the toilet?
Into retailing of beer
and building out facilities?
Are you out of your mind?
Why would you want to do that
to yourself?
I'll tell you why.
There's a big quality-control
issue in a lot of the beer
that you can make.
You're breaking my heart.
You're breaking my heart, Henry.
It's something that we can't
maintain the quality
in someone else's facility,
and that is something that will
really disappoint the customers
and turn them away,
never to come back.
So maintaining
that facility on our own --
You know, I-I don't --
I don't believe that statement,
because, I mean, look --
I-It's such a shame.
I could show you
how to fix this
and make you millions
of dollars,
and you're too stubborn.
I want to spank you
like a baby seal.
-You got a paddle.
-You got a paddle right here.
Just, like,
that is such a mistake.
-Oh, my God.
-He welcomes the spank.
It's just -- that's terrible.
Listen, Henry.
I'm sorry.
I'm heartbroken.
It's such a cool model
with such a flaw.
What a crime.
Yeah. I don't believe that
that's true, but --
-Are you in?
-It's true.
I'm out.
Henry, thank you.
high-quality product.
-Greiner: Thanks, Henry.
-Thank you, guys.
Good luck.
Schwartz: Kevin thought
I was a little silly
for not outsourcing
my manufacturing,
but in the craft-beer world,
it's really important
to have an identity,
so I'm happy to be able to say
that we're gonna go through
and build out
our brewery facility
to make our wonderful beer.
Narrator: In season 4,
we watched cowboy Ryan Ehmann
make a deal with Daymond John
for his exercise DVDs
"Lose 12 Inches in 12 Workouts."
Now that's what
I'm talking about!
Let's see
what he's up to now.
These last three years
have been one heck of a ride.
Whee!
I did $80,000 in Internet sales
in 6 weeks after airing.
I was so sure that my online
business was gonna take off,
so I made the decision
to close my gym
and solely focus
on the Internet business.
All of a sudden,
the Internet sales dropped off
and I didn't know how
to pay my mortgage.
I was scared, you know?
I got two little kids at home.
I got a wife,
and there aren't...
I-I'm their rock.
It's all on my shoulders.
That's when Daymond showed me
his true colors
and sent me a check
to pay my mortgage.
He told me that I was the face
and the brand of the business
and I needed to get back on my
feet and build it back up again.
All right, ladies,
get on the bull!
All: Go!
I spent two years
working like crazy
to build a gym
that was rodeo-themed.
I call it Cowboys Gym.
Come on. Come on.
My gym has been so successful,
I'm opening my second location.
Between both gyms
and the Internet sales,
I generated over $750,000.
Cowboy!
-[ Laughs ]
-What's up?
I decided to help Ryan out
because we've become friends,
and I believed in him.
He just made some really bad
business moves,
but he learned his lessons
the hard way.
I love it.
This is truly different
than anything I've seen before,
and franchising Cowboy Ryan's
workout program
will definitely
put him on the map.
So glad that we stuck
with each other.
You can't give up, and if things
aren't going your way
in the business
you're working on,
you've just got to rework it.
You've got to just keep going.
And it's pretty amazing
where I'm at now.
Whoo-hoo!
All:
That's what I'm talking about!
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a fashion brand
that helps express
one's unique style.
Hi, I'm Jeremiah Robison
from Provo, Utah.
My company is Beloved Shirts,
and I am seeking $175,000
in exchange for 5%.
The problem with the world today
is that it's just too serious.
So we as a society
woke up one day,
and everything
was just plain boring.
So to combat the
over-seriousness of the world,
I came up with Beloved Shirts.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughs ]
I'm actually
a huge introvert,
so you'd think I'd be fine
going by unnoticed
in whatever lifeless clothes
I was wearing before,
but my real personality,
which is a lot weirder
than I let on,
wouldn't stand
for a serious Jeremiah.
So here I am,
a man hugging a unicorn,
asking for you
to invest in my idea.
Together, we can make the world
a lot more colorful.
I got some customized samples
I want to pass out.
-John: Great.
-Greiner: Great.
He's the pizza man.
-Are those pizza slices?
Yes, it's pepperoni.
All right.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Looking good.
Thank you, sir.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
-Lori...
-[ Laughs ]
If you're nice, you might
get this for Christmas.
That's gonna go over big
at my house. I can tell.
[ Laughter ]
So what --
what's the business?
That was just for fun,
to show us the product.
Yeah, so,
what we're passionate about
is just creating apparel
that warrants a reaction.
It's a way
to express yourself.
We feel like we're selling
an experience
and not just
a product here.
Katy Perry had that fleece on
a few years ago.
Yeah, Katy Perry is
our biggest influencer by far.
But was that pizza one yours
that she wore?
Yeah.
That was ours.
We didn't reach out
to her at all.
This was totally random,
and she just loves the brand.
What -- What does it cost?
Onesies -- by far our most
expensive item -- $129 retail.
And what's a t-shirt cost?
T-shirt costs $39.95.
And what are your margins?
Our cost to goods sold
percentage range
is between 58% and 60%
right now.
Everything's made in the USA.
Cuban: How many, um, different
products do you have?
How much to you typically have
dollar-wise in inventory?
So, to start this business, I
didn't invest in any inventory.
Like, in fact, all I needed
was $300 for my first sample.
So everything's made-to-order,
and that, you know,
it's bittersweet.
It has its pros -- we don't have
to invest in inventory,
we can put whatever we want
to market right away,
but the turnaround times
is our biggest struggle.
How long is the turnaround?
Right now, we're advertising
30-day turnarounds
on our website.
-Wow.
Jeremiah, what were
your sales last year?
Last year,
we did $2.3 Million.
-Cuban: Good for you.
-Nice.
$2.3 Million?
How long you been in business?
-Two and a half years.
-Wow.
How much did you make
on the $2.3 million?
Last year,
our net profit was 10%.
Okay, but should I pay
five times your cash flow?
Value at $1 million --
is that what you're worth?
I think we are on track
to really scaling this company
and improving our profits
just by simply automating
the back-end system.
Our biggest struggle right now
is our turnaround times.
You know --
Why haven't you automated it
up to this point?
We have 22,000 SKUs
on the website.
-Wow.
-It's the artwork.
-Oh, I hate that.
-That's a huge amount of SKUs.
Why do you have so many?
Well, it's all
the different sizes.
So technically, it's a lot less
when you see the amount
of designs,
but we do all the way
up to 3XL and extra small.
You've put a value on your
business at $3.5 million.
I'm looking at it
as five times cash flow.
You're smart enough to know
that's not an unreasonable --
Kevin doesn't understand that
companies actually do grow.
He just thinks that
they stay the same size.
O'Leary: Well, he's not growing.
I'm a reasonable guy.
What multiple
for a t-shirt company
should I put on
cash flow?
You don't put it on cash flow
at this point.
You want to know
how he's gonna grow.
So you're not
a disciplined investor.
You will make foolish decisions.
[ Chuckles ]
The challenge is
what's your angle, right?
Because the thing that concerns
me is you based it on hype.
-Yeah.
-Right?
For you to grow to get to
$5 million, $10 million.
How are you gonna do it?
So, I do have plans to get into
mass distribution.
You want to go into retail?
-Uh, very selectively.
-Oof.
I want to be selective about the
retailers that carry our brand.
What are you gonna
use the money for?
So your margins are really
gonna change, though,
you know,
if you go into retail.
Like, right now,
you said you're making...
-60% margins.
-60%.
But you're gonna have to
wholesale them.
We -- we simply can't
go into mass distribution
with our on-demand
business model.
So part of the reason I'm here
for a partnership with a shark
is to secure additional
manufacturing relationships
where we can do these
high-volume runs.
What are you --
what are you gonna use the --
the --
the $175,000 for?
So primarily,
because I know
we're good at
direct-to-consumer --
that's something
I'm confident in --
I do want to improve
our conversion rate
by speeding up
those turnarounds.
How many do you convert?
So we are at a 1% conversion
right now, which is low.
Just 1%?
That's horrible, yeah.
They see
our 30-day turnaround,
and I-I know that's
what's scaring people away.
Jeremiah, I think you deserve
a lot of congratulations
-for having built this.
-Thank you.
You know, um,
you've had a lot of success,
but I don't think
you've really
got your act
completely together yet.
You're still kind of
operating by the --
the pizza of your pants,
you know?
[ Chuckles ]
And so you come here looking for
a shark for that help,
-which is a good thing...
-Yeah.
...but I don't think
you're there yet,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
Appreciate that.
Herjavec: Jeremiah, I think
it's an incredible job --
$2.5 million from zero
in two and a half years...
-Thank you.
-...it's really fun stuff,
but I've already invested
in a fun company
called Tipsy Elves.
It's too similar a market
for me.
-I'm out.
-Appreciate it. Thanks.
I think you're very SKU-heavy,
which, to me,
it seems you probably know
or can figure out
what are your top 50 sellers,
top 20 sellers.
You know, hone it in.
I would feature and work on
and maybe start to inventory
and warehouse the tops
so that then you can
ship them out immediately.
-It's the Lori-advice tank.
-Yeah, well --
I'm glad
you brought that up,
'cause that's
what we're doing right now.
We've actually reduced
the amount of SKUs, you'll see,
by a third already
just last month,
-so we're sifting through them.
-But this would allow you --
if you think you're losing
all your customers,
only a 1% conversion rate
because they see it's 30 days...
-Uh-huh.
-All you have to do
-is warehouse the top 10 things.
-Great idea.
Great warehouses here.
Ship them out overnight.
Problem solved.
You know?
I would suggest to do that.
For me, I don't feel
that this is investable
at this point in time,
so I'm out.
Okay.
I just look at it from, uh,
the discipline of a financial
investor and say to myself
you're not worth more than
five times cash flow.
You're worth $1 million.
You're asking for $3.5 million.
I think that's ridiculous.
And unfortunately, Jeremiah,
I'm gonna have to forbid Daymond
from doing this deal.
He needs -- He's going to have
to get at least 17.5%
or I won't allow it.
-I'm out.
-Thanks.
I have so many levels
of concern.
You offered 5%.
Why just 5%?
You know,
I'm willing to negotiate.
5% is the starting point.
I'm prepared to give away
more equity if necessary.
Because
there's a lot of work here,
I have to -- I have to offer you
the $175,000 for 25%.
I permit that deal.
I valued this company at
one and a half times revenue
and feel it was pretty fair,
but I am willing to negotiate.
Would you agree to 15%?
Hmm.
-Don't do it.
-There's a --
-Close to Kevin's 17%.
-17.5% is fair.
22.5%.
That's just too much equity
for that amount of money.
I have to do a lot of work.
-Okay.
-And you're gonna need --
You're gonna need to
turn around these goods
way, way quicker, so I'm gonna
have to stick with the 22.5%.
♪♪
Okay. I respectfully decline
that offer.
Well, that means
you're dead to me.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you for your time.
I appreciate it.
-Thank you.
-Uh-huh. Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
Thanks for the shirt.
Guess we can't show this.
[ All sigh ]
Bye bye,
pizza guy with beard.
Well, all is not lost.
-These are really attractive.
-[ Chuckles ]
Oh, here.
Put my shirt on with them.
That's just amazing.
Yeah, that's who you want
to go to bed with.
[ Laughs ]
That's a really confusing
outfit.
[ Laughter ]
Narrator: Next up is a product
that helps light the way.
♪♪
Hey, sharks.
I'm Matt Alexander.
And I'm Mike Kannely, and
our product is IllumiBowl.
We're seeking $100,000 in
exchange for 15% of our company.
Sharks, it's time to explain
the toilet in the room.
Each night,
millions of people
awake to the call of
mother nature.
They stumble out of bed,
into the bathroom,
and they're faced with a
terrible choice --
turn on blinding lights
and wake themselves up
or go it alone
in the dark.
Neither is a good option.
So don't make that choice.
Get IllumiBowl.
[ Herjavec chuckles ]
The IllumiBowl is a way
to do your business
in a whole new light.
IllumiBowl
is a motion-activated,
toilet-bowl night-light.
It easily attaches to
the edge of any bowl
and automatically
turns itself on
anytime you enter the room
at night.
So what that means is
there's no more blinding lights,
just a soft glow
where you need to go.
It's simple, small,
and clean.
Its modern design and
state-of-the-art manufacturing
means it'll light up your
bathroom for years and years.
At IllumiBowl, our main
priorities are -- number one...
and number two.
[ Laughter ]
So, sharks...
So don't let this opportunity
go to waste.
We'll get you
some samples.
Thanks, Matt.
Here's the packaging, and
then you can take it out.
Greiner: Thank you.
John: Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
So, does this light
stay on, uh,
your entire visit to the --
to the bathroom?
Yeah, so it's on --
it's on a two-minute timer.
And so
if you're longer than that,
it just sees motion,
and it turns back on again.
-So when the m-- Okay.
-So you have to move.
How close do you have to be
to it for it to motion-activate?
It depends on the bathroom,
actually.
It'll turn on some bathrooms
right at the door,
some you have to be within
two -- two, three feet of it.
Matt,
what's the difference --
I mean, why don't I just put
a night-light in the bathroom?
A lot of our --
our current customers
purchase this instead of
a night-light,
'cause the night-light's still
pretty bright when you walk in.
It lights up the whole room
and it wakes you up, and also,
this lights up just exactly
where you're aiming for --
-just headed to.
-If you're a guy.
Herjavec: You know,
when my kids were little,
we had night-lights
in all the rooms.
Like, the little,
green night-lights.
They're very soft.
You put them in there.
Kids would see
where the toilet is.
You're saying that it's better
because it's targeted.
-That's it.
-It is targeted.
-It's also very fun.
-It is fun. I'll give you that.
Is there any risk of electric
shock in the urine stream?
[ Laughter ]
-No. No.
-Zero.
Zero.
What happens when
you go to clean the toilet?
So the dirtiest parts
of the toilet
are actually the front
and the back.
That's why we designed it
to go on the side.
And then you just wipe
it off with whatever you
clean your toilet with.
How does that come on and off?
Can you take it on and off?
Yeah, so it just
suction-cups on and off.
-Oh, it's a suction.
-Oh, it's a suction cup.
You adjust it
to your toilet size --
Matt,
how many have you sold?
We've sold 6,500 units.
How much is it?
$100,000.
We did a kickstarter
around last November.
Wait, wait.
Wh-- how much is it?
-$100,000 total.
-Oh, oh.
How much is the unit?
I'm sorry.
-You sold 6,500.
-How much is each one?
-What does each one cost?
-We're selling them for $19.99.
And you've done $100,000
all on kickstarter.
-All on kickstarter.
-What's your landed cost?
Landed cost is $3.98, and
that's packaged and assembled.
-Oh!
-Whoa!
Oh, my God!
Kevin, that could have been
your pee-pee!
-What happened?
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
Fortunately, the actual product
is actually a lot smaller,
so there's no risk
of that happening.
Yeah, you don't have giant
toilets falling on you.
Bringing down the house.
That was scary.
Do you guys
have any retail today?
Do you have any
retail sales?
Not yet, and we're meeting with
retailers now.
What are you gonna do
with the money?
Inventory.
So the vision is,
we're gonna launch online
beginning in a couple of weeks,
when we get our im--
when we import,
and we'll fulfill
all those pre-orders,
and then we've been meeting with
just local stores.
Some -- through Krogers, there's
a Smith's stores in Utah,
and they want to get it in all
their stores to do a local run.
And she can get us in faster,
and then we've been meeting with
some Ace Hardwares, 'cause
they can do individual buys,
and just work our way into
larger retail stores.
Down the road, we're actually
looking into projecting images.
-You could get --
-Projecting images?
-What --
-What would you project
on a turd?
[ Laughter ]
Well, a football team
you don't like.
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
Herjavec: Stop it!
The horror! The horror!
I'm in. I'm in. I'm in.
I'll buy every run you have.
Aim right for the mouth.
We're focusing on
what we have now,
because
the demand's been huge.
Ahh, I know just how to
put some hair on that head.
[ Laughter ]
So you were just saying that
demand's been huge. By who?
So, when we launched
the kickstarter,
honestly, we were just
validating through the process,
so when I wanted to know if it
was a legitimate idea or not --
so we did it on kickstarter
and we --
we figured all we needed
to get started
for all the tooling and molding
was 20 grand.
And we did no --
it was all organic.
We didn't pay for advertising,
for marketing, for anything.
It went to 100 grand,
and then we've just had
a lot of distributors
started reaching out to us.
-So you need cash for inventory.
-That's the inventory.
And this is the unit
you're gonna sell,
and then somebody's gonna
knock it off if it sells a lot.
-They'll just change something.
-It's a first-to-market game.
Why do you need cash inventory
if you have --
-you have $100,000 now, correct?
-Yeah, so we have to fulfill --
And you got the money up front
from kickstarter.
And $4 per unit, right?
So 1,000 units -- $4,000. Right?
So you can have -- On a bad day,
you can have 10,000 units.
Mm-hmm. So yeah,
we're shipping in 10,000 units,
6,500 already spoken for.
So that only leaves 3,000 units
to deal with.
Sure.
So that's not gonna
last very long.
But I mean, that's --
that's -- that's the beauty of,
and that's what
most entrepreneurs
have in common
that are successful.
They take affordable next steps.
You don't need us.
Take affordable next steps.
I'm out.
It is patent pending, so it's a
first-to-market game, honestly.
We can
grow slower organically,
and we still will
if we have to, but --
'cause we have turned down
investors to this point.
-What's your competition,
though?
-It's two guys
and a toilet-bowl light,
basically, right?
-Yeah.
-Okay, look. I like it.
It's kind of nuts.
I'll give you 100 grand for 25%.
Guys, I-I see this
as novelty item.
Doesn't mean you can't
make money off of it.
Congratulations.
You guys thought it through
and your sweat equity is turning
into a real business for you,
but it's a product,
it's not a company.
-Sure.
-And for that reason, I'm out.
-Thank you, Mark.
-You're welcome.
Um, so yeah, absolutely.
So when we --
and respond to you, too.
Well, I wouldn't -- listen.
I wouldn't sit on the bowl
too long.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I'd -- I'd, uh --
-Do you see this for women?
-I'll be very honest, guys.
Did you do
any market research?
You know, a lot of our buyers
are women, actually.
They want to use it
for potty training
-their kids and their husbands.
-Yeah, clever.
We got a lot of wives
and mothers
to use it to help their kids,
'cause their kids are scared
to go to the bathroom
in the dark
alone at night.
Mike, I -- look.
I-I think
you're gonna run fast.
You did $100,000 in sales.
You can buy more inventory.
I won't make you a better offer
than Kevin's made you.
Frankly, I think you need
a brand to this.
You need a face
that people associate with
-toilet paper and toilets.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I think, you know...
You got the best offer
when it comes to that.
...you think flushing away
stuff, Kevin's your guy.
-Okay.
-I'm out.
-Oh.
-So Kevin, would you --
That is an incredible offer.
So it did --
It was a lot of work
to get here,
and we do see
how this can scale.
Would you be willing to meet
in the middle with that?
No. This is a light
for a toilet bowl.
-Let's be realistic.
-Sure.
Greiner: Well, I want to share
with you something, too.
-Sure.
-You know, I did a deal with
a product called
Squatty Potty.
Mm-hmm.
Seen it.
And they have done
almost $8 million in six months.
-Wow.
-But one of the things
that they're doing
is a lot of extensions.
-Mm-hmm.
-One has illumination,
and I would not want
to be competitive...
-Conflict of interest.
-...with anything that
you're doing or to do something
that steps on
what they're doing.
-I'm out.
-Thank you, Lori.
So,
you have an offer from Kevin.
It's $100,000 for 25%.
What do you think?
♪♪
-Sounds pretty good.
-I think we should.
-I think you got a deal, Kevin.
-Yeah.
Let's light up those toilets.
Herjavec: He is the perfect face
for your brand.
Kevin, you're now
in the toilet business.
[ Laughter ]
-I like that.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, Kevin.
-Take care. Ciao.
I am gonna light
America's toilets up.
Alexander: It is a dream come
true, honestly. It really was.
We've watched this show
for years
and never thought I'd actually
be up here making a deal
and making my own
American dream come true.
Narrator: Next up
is a company dedicated to
making interesting products
for our animal friends.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
I'm Victoria Coopman.
And I'm Tim Taft.
And we're the owners of
Innovation Pet.
We're seeking $250,000
for 5% interest in our company.
-Oh. Oh, that hurts.
-$250,000 for 5%?
Whether you're a dog lover
or a crazy cat lady,
people love their pets.
It's no secret
that having a pet
changes your life
for the better,
so why not
make their lives better?
That's why Victoria and I
started Innovation Pet.
We manufacture all kinds
of pet products --
dog toys, dog houses,
cat play systems,
and yes, even our magical
chicken coops.
Innovation Pet
has just begun to make its mark
as leaders in innovation,
so which one of you sharks
want to
paw, scratch, or peck
your way in and join our team?
-[ Laughs ]
-Can we see a demo?
Yes, absolutely.
Why don't we start with
the magical Kitty Connection.
So this has, by far,
been one of our most popular
product launches.
If you have a cat at home,
you know
that cats get very bored.
They need to have motion.
They need to have something.
The best-selling categories
in cat toys
are cat toys, scratching items,
and cat furniture.
The Kitty Connection
is all three of those.
It's got
scratching components --
corrugate and carpet.
Then you can build it up.
It's modular, so you can
constantly create a new toy.
Change it up.
And the biggest feature
on this --
we have an internal pulley
system,
so when the cat
plays with one toy,
it moves
another one on there,
so it creates its own motion
on there.
That's the Kitty Connection.
-Dog houses --
-The dog house is very cool.
Yeah, it's -- Robert,
if you know, dog houses, today,
are real boxy.
There's really not a lot of
fashion or trends in them.
Oh, I know a lot about
being in the dog house.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Well, you'd want to be
in this one. This one's cute.
This has, by far, been
our most popular launch.
We call it
the Whimsical Dog House.
And, by the way,
we have 10 products
in the Innovation pipeline
that we're working on right now.
-Coming out?
-Is there any you can share?
We're creating --
And this is just a prototype.
We're gonna call it
the Magic Carpet,
and it's gonna
have toys hanging off it
so that you can
have the cat chase it.
It'll be a carpeted
scratching surface on top
so they can lay on top of it,
and they love riding it around.
And then you
remote-control operate it?
And we're also working on
something you can use
on your phone.
So would I
drive the cat around?
Yep.
The cat jumps on,
scratches, plays with the toys,
jumps off.
Tell us about
the chicken thing.
The chicken coops -- this is
a magical category for us.
All the coops out there
on the market today
-only have one little door.
-Hey.
So one of the different things
about our coops
is we have a patent pending,
free-range door on ours.
Can you open it
so we can see it?
Yeah, yeah.
So we basically --
It has two latches,
and the whole front of the coop
lifts up and opens.
The lower portion, so that
they're able to go in and out
and come back during the day
when they want food and water.
So, I just purchased six chicken
coops for my Guinea hens.
-[ Laughs ]
-I did.
Wow.
And they can be expensive,
actually.
I would say that one is,
fully assembled, $700.
No way.
Way more than that.
This one is gonna retail
for about $599.
-That's --
-That's it?
Good chicken coop.
Great price.
So then it's a better price
than what he paid.
Daymond,
if you have chickens,
you'll know that, um,
8 out of 10 people
who have backyard flocks --
they let them out to
run around the yard, so if --
when you're free-ranging
your birds,
at the end of the night,
you want to get them back in
to really keep them safe from
predators, coyotes, raccoons.
So they'll coop them
at the end of the night.
Well, I don't know when
we're gonna get to this...
[ Laughter ]
...but you've put a value of
$5 million on this business.
Um, yeah.
This year, um, we're --
We're gonna hit
$2.5 million in sales.
Wow.
So tell us
how you're getting that.
Is this online?
Through retail?
Do the big boxes
play with you guys?
Yes. Yes, basically,
to all those questions.
Um, so today our customer-base
is pet specialty --
number one -- mainly
with the Kitty Connection.
-So this is not big box?
-No, there is big box.
Well, like, PetCo,
things like that.
PetCo and PetSmart.
So do you sell in large animal
and pet-oriented stores?
Yes. In fact, the
Kitty Connection's in PetCo.
You have a lot
of different products.
Just give me
the average margin of sales.
We're at 27% gross margins.
That's not so good.
Um,
it depends on the category.
So a lot of our dollars,
and some of the coops
aren't as high-margin,
and some of the smaller items
are higher margin.
Victoria, what would your margin
be if you didn't have the coops?
-Above 40%.
-Yeah.
-Ohh.
They are driving dollars
that we don't make a lot on,
but we don't touch them.
There's very little
logistical cost.
Right, so you're turning --
It's basically found money
-because it's
drop-shipped there.
-Yep.
I think
the design is beautiful.
You guys obviously know
what you're doing.
$250,000 for 5% --
it's so small.
A lot of inventory,
a lot of churn.
You're gonna need
way more capital.
I don't know how I would get in
at a significant equity today,
because I think you've actually
maybe valued it fairly,
and I just see so much more
coming down the road.
I can't help you
with distribution.
You're already there.
I'm out.
♪♪
Guys, I think you're brilliant
with what you're doing.
The innovation approach,
you know, just going out there
and getting as much real estate
as you can.
It's a smart play,
and you would think obvious,
but obviously
it hasn't been done before.
So it's great, but it doesn't
really fit my wheelhouse.
You've seen one chicken coop,
you've seen them all.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I'm out.
Two sharks are out.
Three are still in.
Company has sales --
really bad margins.
-Maybe --
-$5 million value today.
Well,
that's a different problem.
I identified that as soon
as the chickens were squawking.
'Cause they are complaining.
I speak chicken.
I'm listening
to what they're saying.
[ Laughter ]
They know you guys.
I'm telling you. The problem
with the deal is the 5%.
I mean, not exciting.
I see your future
more of a licensing play,
because I think
you're the brains
in making and innovating
products
and not having to worry about
what your margin is.
Just license it to the big guys
if it's selling so well.
But I don't want to go changing
your whole structure, right?
I'm out.
♪♪
O'Leary: You don't need help
creating product.
What you really need
is factoring.
You need money.
So the question is,
for any investor,
is how do I get my money back?
Narrator: Three sharks are out,
but Kevin may be interested in
Tim and Victoria's pet product
company Innovation Pet.
So the question is,
for any investor,
is how do I get my money back?
Do we take the chicken coop
public at some point?
[ Chuckles ]
Or does it get acquired
by somebody else?
Or do you pay it off?
I mean, I-I'd do this deal
with you --
I'd give you the $250,000.
I'd like to double my money.
So I'd like you to pay me
a 6% royalty on sales
until I get $500,000 back,
and I'll take the 5% equity now,
because I'm your banker now.
And so I'm incentivized for you
to get me back as fast as I can.
I don't have a time limit on it.
What I'd try and do is
accelerate sales.
-So $250,000, 6% --
-It's venture debt.
So that means
it's gonna take me,
depending what you do in sales,
three and a half years
to get it back.
At least you get a deal...
unless Daymond wants to step up
and, uh, he loves chickens.
We know
this is your space.
John:
Yeah. You know, the 5%.
What wiggle room do you have?
Are you -- are you willing
to kind of move that around?
-Yeah.
-I-I-If -- if --
If we can get
the PO financing.
I want to take that financing
challenge off your plate.
I understand that's
the biggest hurdle you have.
I will give you the $250,000,
and my intent is to go out,
license or strategic
relationship,
whatever the case is.
I will give you that
for 12.5% of the company,
but 25% of online.
Because
I'll build online for you.
-That's expensive.
-So Daymond,
you're gonna give them $250,000
for 12.5% equity right away,
plus you want
25% of the profit...
-Of online.
-...of any online sales.
And I will build the online.
And right now you don't have
a lot of online,
so he's gonna
build it for you.
So it's newfound money.
I'm trying to find
newfound money for you,
and I've already
consulted with Darnell.
-[ Laughs ]
-Darnell been here for me.
-Aw.
-He's told me
what we need to do.
You guys want to
step out and talk?
A lot of discussion
going on here.
[ Laughs ]
They're laughing at you,
Kevin.
It's okay.
Daymond, did you say you'd help
us PO finance as well?
Yes. Of course. I'm gonna take
that off the -- off the plate.
Kevin, we're very flattered
by your offer,
um, just because strategically
we feel that
Daymond could also be
a good fit in the company.
Absolutely,
he is a chicken.
And Daymond,
you have a deal.
All right.
Darnell, you hear that, baby?
[ Laughs ]
All right.
Thank you, man.
Appreciate it.
-Thanks.
-Thank you.
I am so excited.
Cuban: Congrats, guys.
We did it, man.
I am so excited.
-Yeah.
-That was so great.
Having Daymond
as a strategic partner for us
is gonna be phenomenal.
Our online business,
we anticipate's
going to probably
quadruple overnight.
Yeah.
So we're very excited
about that,
and it's going to be able to get
our product out to more people,
and that's our goal.
-Right. Right.
-That's our goal.
♪♪